hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcasted just checking in on ya I'm
checking in on you hey I'll tell you
something that's gonna be coming back I
don't give a [ __ ] how they're gonna do
it because they always do it they don't
give a [ __ ] what's going on is the NFL I
know the NHL is trying to [ __ ] you
know Tom Dick and Harry whatever the
[ __ ] they're trying to do right I don't
know what the NBA is doing I don't what
the [ __ ] any of them do I know the NFL's
coming back they don't give a [ __ ] all
right
the real reason Trump did not lock down
in time was the NFL told endure and then
the next week Trump was like a little ad
about math they said we got the Pro Bowl
all right then after that that was it
then they shot the [ __ ] thing down so
virus no virus tuberculosis was
something else I heard was getting
thrown around out there
tuberculosis season it's like didn't we
cure that [ __ ] did we care that [ __ ] oh
just did just enough did everybody who
had it died I don't know I don't want to
such things off all I know is I just
looked up a bunch of [ __ ] on Cam Newton
right and he seems like he's [ __ ]
pissed off and ready to prove something
you know and all these Patriot haters
were all excited that Tom Brady signed
with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers and lo and
behold we got one of the best
quarterbacks in the league for the
league minimum huh which means they got
money for other weapons I think it's
gonna be tremendous I want to see what
Bill Belichick does with a guy that can
actually is also a threat to run okay
it's gonna be [ __ ] amazing and this
guy was saying that our offensive line
is going to be looking good
I don't give a [ __ ] if they play in
front of five people they got to bring
football
all right everybody knows football is
what keeps America sane you know and I
know all you [ __ ] haters of America in
your different countries where every one
of you thinks she the first clever [ __ ]
to say what it call it football oh I
know [ __ ] do they call it football what
a [ __ ] they [ __ ] kick it off you [ __ ]
the kick field goals they punt it's a
[ __ ] kick like every three goddamn
place why don't you guys work on not
[ __ ] crying
anytime anybody on the other team looks
at you and and start having some [ __ ]
Shakespearean opera going on out there
Jesus Christ well I can't think why
can't the people that play rugby play
soccer and give soccer some [ __ ]
goddamn respect around the globe Jesus
Christ bunch of beta males running
around flip-flop at any time anybody
[ __ ] touches their sock the top of
their [ __ ] shoe
I like women's soccer better than the
women just go out and plays [ __ ] guys
bunch of goddamn broads sorry anyways I
got nothing guys I I just I just think
of something and I just I exhaust the
topic because I am not doing anything
okay I am I got nothing I have no road
gigs I'm in California they're shutting
it down again I think it is shut it shut
down I don't know what the [ __ ] going
on so all I've been doing is every day I
try to go on some sort of a outdoor
activity with my family back east you
know have the masks on and all that [ __ ]
and it's still [ __ ] [ __ ] walk it
around no max they don't need all my
favorite they have the mask on but it's
like but beneath their nose you dumb
[ __ ] just push it I would be like in a
cartoon you know I mean you could pull
the mass back and then stick some TNT in
there and then let it go right into
their face that's what I that's what I
think about doing among other things but
you know I don't do it I don't do it you
know there we sitting there talking
about what mass
shaming I'm not going to do that alright
I got two bad shoulders I'm on the other
side of 50 okay you know the best you're
gonna get out of me is a dirty look
until you make eye contact with me and
then I'm gonna look away like the weak
dog in the litter okay that's all I have
left at this point you know before I was
50 I used to I was really good at
pretending I knew how to fight but f you
now that I'm on the other side what's
great about it once you're in the other
side of 50 you can finally admit to the
world that you actually actually admit
to yourself that you're not really good
at it you don't really want to do it
Eddie
so yeah I think I want to see what the
[ __ ] this is gonna look like and I'm a
little nervous that it's the beginning
of July and nobody's talking about
football as far as like is it gonna come
back let me let me check my smartphone
here let me see if this [ __ ] thing's
gonna come back come on people I mean
Jesus Christ this you know I actually
was listening to a little bit of NPR
today in other words I was driving in
the car with my wife you know and they
just had these two women discussing that
Trump's gonna cut funding on schools
that don't open in the fall and oh my
god now they're gonna sit her in trash
Trump and then but they didn't they were
actually sitting they go well you know
it's difficult to try to please
everybody the kids don't really seem to
get it but if you open the school I mean
there's a bunch of adults teaching that
me and you know you don't want them to
you know catch it and then [ __ ]
breathe on somebody else and then they
die
but then again we got to move forward
and I just I was listening to this [ __ ]
I actually asked I actually turned it
off my wife was like I was living
through that so I turned it back on
turned it back on because I have
realized that my idea of sanity is not
my wife's idea and that I am also insane
right I'm insane she's insane
okay but I just think she's insane
because her idea of sanity is not my
idea sanity right that makes that I did
I [ __ ] have I given you a clue the
bareness they'll come to you every night
I gotta sing that to my daughter look
for the bare necessities the simple bare
necessities forget about Joe then when
you pick a paw paw what does that mean
or a prickly pear and you prick the raw
paw well next time beware don't pick the
prickly pear with the poor when you pick
the pear try to use the claw oh god damn
it I need to go do a [ __ ] stand-up
gig all right this is the new [ __ ]
this is the new normal you wake up you
take your vitamins you go outside you
either get it and live you don't get it
or you get it you die and that's it
that's it I think kovetz here to stake
it's [ __ ] here to stake and you
either this is this is Mother Nature's
just like you [ __ ] [ __ ] you walking
on your [ __ ] feet [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] up every river every ocean every
[ __ ] tree you made a mockery of a
knob a day Arbor Day whatever the [ __ ]
it is Ann Arbor go blue I think she's
just like all right all these [ __ ]
white women saying enough is enough you
know what I'm the original [ __ ] I'm
saying enough is enough and I'm [ __ ]
unleashing this [ __ ] and I'll give a
[ __ ] um what the [ __ ] you guys are gonna
do alright it is time I have let you I
have let the weak survive for long
enough with this race of [ __ ] animals
every other [ __ ] rate every other
species wrong [ __ ] word every species
of animal the weak have got to go that's
what Mother Nature's say is that what
she's saying or are we just [ __ ]
I don't know I don't know what I just I
don't know what I'm gonna do here I'm
have to take up another [ __ ] hobby
you know
I am literally out of [ __ ] to talk about
I Drive around on my car and I look at
houses that I like and then I go and I
go on Zillow and I get really
disappointed if they have a bit on the
market and I can't see pictures of every
[ __ ] room in there how weird is that
you know and I was mentioning the other
day that I actually like Craftsman style
houses but I gotta tell you this after
you know being basically at the
gentlemen's peeping-tom because I'm not
looking at anybody I am looking into
your house but none of you guys are
there and I'm doing it on Zillow right
I've actually I I love the way a
craftsman house looks from the outside
you get inside the [ __ ] thing it's
just a little too creepy for me not into
it
so I'm think I'm dead at Iranian style
houses and then I like those
ridiculously modern looking ones oh and
me and my [ __ ] lovely wife watched
this show one of these real estate shows
and there's this guy he's this builder
and he actually did a photo shoot you
know like smoking a cigar and [ __ ] and
Nia just started laughing like who the
[ __ ] is this ridiculous person I'm like
I don't know I love this guy already
though why is he smoking a cigar like he
just wants some sort of championship you
know and then I was like wait I smoked
cigars so why the [ __ ] not
like but I never did a photo shoot
that's a tough one it's really tough to
do a photo shoot with the cigar as a guy
and not look like a douche you know but
then again that's what I love about a
cigar other than the delicious taste of
a cigar is I just love how [ __ ]
obnoxious it is it's like I'm gonna
smoke this cigar and everybody in a
quarter-mile radius is gonna be aware
that I am smoking one so anyway this guy
he makes these [ __ ] like hundred
million dollar houses I mean how much
fun is that to look at the axe
this thing the environmental disaster
that a [ __ ] 100 million dollar houses
you know I'm not saying that if I didn't
create an app that I then sold for
[ __ ] a billion dollars that I
wouldn't go out and go buy one of these
houses I absolutely would you know it
once a year I would have some homeless
kids come over and I would let them swim
in the the guest pool give us some bag
of candy or some [ __ ] and then I would
be like see I did something I did some
for society so anyways this [ __ ] guy
man I got a you know he literally goes
he's like given the lady all this [ __ ]
right making her take her shoes off
before she enters the house he's gonna
show the house there's the Builder he's
gonna show the house just massive
massive massive like [ __ ] just just
living in his ego at one point he's
gonna I need someone to sell my old
portfolio I'm right now I'm holding five
hundred million dollars in earth right
now is that what you're holding there
buddy right but I gotta tell you this as
much as this guy was living in his
[ __ ] ego which is always of course
entertaining to watch I don't know if
he's ramping up for TV I got to tell you
something this [ __ ] guy's houses were
amazing he's developing this part of
Malibu it's called the case I don't know
why why not right well it's not a
million dollars why not give it a
douchey name she's staying there with
the [ __ ] cigar and a hammer in the
other hand but of architectural plants
this guy makes an amazing amazing
[ __ ] how the house was [ __ ]
gorgeous dude this was just the one next
to the ones that he's gonna make in this
this area and the guy said it has over
4,800 feet of deck space you have like a
mansion square foot that's a mansion
right you get like five thousand square
feet of anything you got it you got a
mansion they have a mansion of a porch
square footage on their porch
but the best part about this is because
this guy loves cigars he actually built
a cigar room you know wine tasting room
and then then there was actually there
was like a million dollars with a wine
in there in the wine room and then next
to that there was a cigar like a [ __ ]
like what do you call a cigar bar like
in the house these four [ __ ] leather
chairs the sick ass smoke eater and then
you could just walk out on the deck and
you could just look at the canyons and
on the other side you could look out the
ocean it was it was and it was not like
gaudy if I could say was it was somehow
an understated hundred million dollar
house I absolutely [ __ ] loved it so
it's I don't know if this is what I'm
doing to get through it I'm just looking
at ridiculous [ __ ] houses I just
can't [ __ ] imagine that you should
have seen this thing it would like you
would get tired walking from the kitchen
to the [ __ ] living room and you know
what's funny is you know you ever buys
that thing is gonna live there with like
two or three other people it'd be like
living in a mall with like five other
people that's like one of those houses
where you just like where the [ __ ] is my
phone ah Christ get on a Segway the
other side of the [ __ ] house I would
think you'd get skinnier in that house
just doing all that walking you know and
then when you're late at night laying in
your bed you're just thinking like ah
man I'd love a [ __ ] ice-cream
sandwich fit out the kitchen is like a
quarter of a mile away
you know when you buy a house that big
you actually have to have a property
manager you have to have somebody manage
the property just to make sure the
[ __ ] shrubs clipped make sure
somebody puts the [ __ ] red flag down
on your [ __ ] mailbox I don't know
that house was so unbelievable that like
you know if you were living in that
thing right then if the Christianity
thing is actually right and Jesus comes
back how [ __ ] nervous are you if
you're sitting in that house all of a
sudden he's you're looking out at the
[ __ ] Pacific Ocean right you know in
5,000 square feet of a [ __ ] deck and
all of a sudden you see Jesus walking on
water he like oh [ __ ] hey what's up son
of God are you doing Jesus just [ __ ]
taking in your giant house not this see
this right here this is what is wrong
with my religion that I was raised on is
that you immediately have all of this
guilt if if you're doing well I mean
what do you think makes you this guy's
you guys hey guys we're all in this
together at send me emails what would
you have to do okay in order to justify
100 million dollar house well this still
this one was actually I think he wanted
to sell it for eighty-five and they
wanted to sell it for 75 and he was very
perturbed about that right I mean it is
10 million bucks you know the man is
holding five hundred million dollars in
earth of Earth I forget how he said it
but it was [ __ ] great I mean that's
the kind of [ __ ] you want to say at a
bar come walking in right all these
[ __ ] fine right that's what the [ __ ]
you want to say then what are you doing
there Silver Fox yeah I'm thinking about
how I'm holding 500 million in earth
right now then the amount of gold
digging ass that would just [ __ ]
would be like glitter in a strip club
except they'd be [ __ ] women anyway
what what do you think you would have to
do you know I would think Elon Musk I
know he's kind of become a polarizing
guy with like everything's become
politics now right but just as far as
like what that guy is doing you know
take it on the big three taking on the
oil companies all that type of [ __ ] and
just you know if an electric world is
actually a cleaner world that guy's
doing he's actually if he actually
improves helps to improve and tip the
scale into people going that direction
and we actually get into solar power
which it's just [ __ ] blows my mind
blows my [ __ ] mind that you're gonna
fight war over this goop or you could
just put these stupid glass tiles on top
of your [ __ ] just give the goddamn
Sun to the oil companies [ __ ] are we
doing anyway I think that guy could live
there and be like yeah well you know but
[ __ ] oceans that I'm looking at is
cleaner cuz of the [ __ ] that I'm selling
to people I know that's a tough one but
if you just were telling jokes like me
[ __ ] jokes okay misogynistic jokes I
think that pretty much covers my act
right yeah [ __ ] jokes misogynistic jokes
right how do you justify that you know I
wonder if when you're in that house and
you get towards the end of your life you
know you got to be thinking like you
know I should really go to a soup
kitchen right now ladle out some [ __ ]
chicken noodle here get something in the
would you do for others type of thing
anyway why am i talking about all this
chicky but gives a [ __ ] you got a you
got a bunch of money you want to live in
that house god bless you go do it I will
tell you this though like you buy that
[ __ ] house and then for whatever
[ __ ] reason someday you got to get
out of it I mean there's like what 20
people in the world that can afford that
house and then you they have to be
looking for a house in that moment and
then like that house that's uh that is I
believe they call that a white elephant
why is it called a white elephant I
don't know why I look at this I'm out my
office I'm you know my wife is still
telling me to do [ __ ] through the text
message
you know my favorite things she's doing
right now she [ __ ] trashes me only
and she trolls me on my Instagram pitch
any time I post something she's always
giving me [ __ ] you know all right
will you take out the trash in the
kitchen it just occurred to me that the
cauliflower is gonna stink up the joint
[Laughter]
all right is that what just occurred to
you all right I'm gonna get into a fight
here we go here's my response hey Nia it
just occurred to me that you have two
legs in two arms in a [ __ ] head that
can tell those limbs to go downstairs
and [ __ ] throw it out yourself you
know when did I become [ __ ] Gary
garbage now why did I want it and on
then I had you and then I Gary garbage I
[ __ ] tanked you know what this is
great I can erase that message
let's do take two all right
hey sweetheart you know what I just
realized you don't just occurred to me
is that you have two legs and two arms
and a brain that could tell you to go
use them to go down there and throw that
stinky ass cauliflower in the [ __ ]
trash I love you that was a better one
see how it sounds
you know it's funny is it did smell like
[ __ ] Gary garbage I got to get back in a
comedy stage I am I am literally
regressing this is like you play guitar
and you just stop playing then all of a
sudden you gonna go back to s be playing
some big gig and you're up there going I
was supposed to be a guitar me playing
twinkle twinkle little star the [ __ ]
cauliflower smelled like [ __ ] right I
was roasting up some vegetables and you
know my sense of smell has been gone for
years I don't know what happened I
breathed in too many chemicals when I
was younger working in a dental office
somewhere along them I just lost my
sense of smell but that [ __ ] I could
just I walked in the liver my was like
honey does this smell bad she goes oh my
god it's terrible right so I went to
throw in the trash it was in a little
plastic container I was like oh wait a
minutes gonna stink up the [ __ ]
kitchen
so what I did was I took out the tape
gun and I [ __ ] went once around it to
lock it down so yeah you know what I'm
gonna [ __ ] send her another voice
message wait a second
yeah that's not to mention yet dumb
husband before he threw it into the into
the garbage
I actually I did the tape gun on it so
it wouldn't stink alright so there's
that so take it you know see I'm off my
game
no that was like that was awful on
purpose you know I did see some great
comedy this week God knows it didn't rub
off on me I was hanging out with my
lovely wife what the [ __ ] else am I
gonna do we're all sitting here at home
and they had all these episodes of South
Park on Comedy Central he watched like
three episodes in a row and we would
just [ __ ] just looking at each other
just dying laughing do you guys see the
Amazon one I don't want to ruin it but I
got to do one line from it you know talk
about everybody just you know malls
nobody going to malls anymore and
everybody getting like [ __ ] packages
delivered by Amazon somehow they tied
Santa Claus into it Santa Claus showed
up and nobody gave a [ __ ] and his exit
line was hey as he walks back to his
sleigh yells back at everybody in South
Park he goes hey have fun suck at besos
dicks
you're a bunch of [ __ ] we laughed about
that for the rest of the [ __ ] episode
we were like Santa not Yuto you're not
being civil Jesus Christ anyways yeah I
got one read one read or another I'm
gonna read it but about up I'd up up up
up um you know what is great about this
[ __ ] pandemic is my office is [ __ ]
cleaned up I love it out here now he's
come out to the garage of me like oh
Jesus this is what I've done with my
life you know now I got it all
[ __ ] catalogued and thrown out or
whatever the [ __ ] needed to happen
excuse me
alright LegalZoom everybody it's a whole
new world in a world out there we're all
faced with new challenges we're all
faced with new challenges if you need
legal help to overcome some of yours
that's where Legal Zoom fits in oh I got
the I got the I got the emoji with the
[ __ ] the tears there for my wife see
that a little bit of humor really helps
the relationship maybe you've been
wondering about the best way to protect
your family or maybe you're thinking
about starting a business but you don't
know the best way to do it
don't let legal questions hold you back
it's just the law now Legal Zoom has
been dedicated to helping you with right
solutions for more than 19 goddamn years
if you're looking to protect your family
with a will or living trust or you're
thinking about the right way to start a
business with a DBA whatever that is an
LLC a non-profit or MOA LegalZoom legal
zooms got you covered it's easy to get
started online and if you need guidance
their network of attorneys can provide
advice to ensure you make the right
choices and since Legal Zoom isn't a law
firm you won't have to leave your home
and you won't get charged by the yawa
visit legalzoom.com today to take care
of some important things you need to get
done that's legalzoom.com
Legal Zoom where life meets legal all
right you know what I need to do in all
fairness I need to let my wife know that
she that those voices texts were on the
podcast and then she'll respond and
hopefully in time or I can play it for
you guys cuz I don't have anything to
talk about coz why don't I know my
password on my [ __ ] phone alright now
I gotta be aboveboard both of those text
messages I did while doing my podcast so
you know the listeners root for you over
me I want to hear your [ __ ] your
response alright alright
all right there we go well close on that
um so uh I've been trying to do better
you know for a long time with my anger
and [ __ ] I got tell yet we have a great
linen closet okay my old ass house that
I spent a [ __ ] fortune on all right
and even still every other outlet it's
just they just they just quit I did they
just quit on me put the plug in all
right and then you're starting to walk
away you know to turn the vacuum on and
then you look over and the plugs you
know I don't want to do it just falls
out of the [ __ ] socket but we have
this linen closet
where you can actually walk into it
which I love you can walk in ooh ooh oh
this there's a there's a washcloth Oh
where's a face cloth on there's a full
towel right oh this the beach towels up
you can walk into it you know what that
says you don't know walk in linen closet
Clinton linen closet says you know what
it says it says flesh okay that is the
[ __ ] problem my wife has this giant
[ __ ] kunti ass plastic green bag full
of [ __ ] full of [ __ ] [ __ ] right well
you would walk in I keep telling her why
don't we just take this giant [ __ ]
bag and get rid of this [ __ ] okay and
she's like I like the bag I finally
figured out why you know why she likes
the bag because it says Martha Stewart
on the side of the [ __ ] thing so
every [ __ ] week when I put away the
[ __ ] laundry after it's been washed I
have to lean over this [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] bag and I had the
loudest slash Quietus meltdown about it
today because I'm really trying not to
snap during all of this [ __ ] you know
what I mean it was one thing when I was
snapping or whatever but then everybody
was you know who gives a [ __ ] that the
bald clowns going on the road in two
days so it wasn't that big a deal but
now now it's like I'm just here so if I
flip out it really [ __ ] drives people
up the wall so
um I'm just making sure she saw this I'm
gonna try to recreate what I said I went
in you know I was trying to put the
washcloth away and there at the back of
the closet and I could have just mosey
dinh there and set them down but instead
I got a [ __ ] reach all the way in
over this you know leaning in over this
[ __ ] bag it's killing my back at
going god damn sick of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] bag of [ __ ] [ __ ] right
[ __ ] diseased stop buying [ __ ] so
I've decided we have a we don't really
have an addict as much as we have like a
[ __ ] crawlspace and I I just looked
at the little thing you push up I am
[ __ ] tomorrow I don't give a [ __ ] how
much my shoulders are talking to me I'm
taking that [ __ ] green bag at plastic
[ __ ] bag no disrespect to Martha
Stewart occasion with jail she did a
time she didn't flip on anybody right
you learn a big lesson there all right
you didn't rat anybody out I'm taking
that [ __ ] bag and I'm sticking it up
in the [ __ ] attic and you know what
this is this is everyone so while you
have to rebell within your relationship
guess what I'm not [ __ ] telling her
I'm doing it dangerous I ain't telling
on doing her I'm taking that [ __ ] bag
all right I'm gonna get my little
stepladder that one I think I did four
steps up and I'm taking that [ __ ]
[ __ ] green [ __ ] bag and I'm
sticking it up there if that's where
it's gonna live I've learned that word
from those [ __ ] high-end things I
really want to smoke a cigar with that
guy who's [ __ ] building those
incredible homes out there in Malibu you
know he said to the lady I'm a [ __ ]
beast and he goes and I'll tell you
right now he goes if you don't do the
job something he goes he she goes if you
screw up I'm gonna fire you and then the
woman goes I don't screw up and I was
sitting there going like they do in a
table read of Top Gun right now I was
waiting for somebody be called Iceman I
never realized real estate had this
level that we watch all of those things
with that
[ __ ] German guy the gay German dude
what's his name that's my favorite there
love
Fredrik or something I don't know what
the [ __ ] his name is I'm like all caught
up and this his [ __ ] guy just moved
out to LA he didn't let the other guy
know you know I'm actually not good with
the names cuz my favorite one is the gay
dude who actually grew up in Los Angeles
and loves Los Angeles and also drives
the old cars that's that's the guy like
the best everybody else I feel is just
carving up this [ __ ] town
he actually cuz one time he went to sell
a house and he knew the history of the
house and he wanted to make sure the
right person got it said he wouldn't gut
it and stick a bunch of [ __ ] IKEA and
Home Depot [ __ ] in there anyway I don't
know what's happened to my life
everybody I got nothing going on look at
my wife won't even [ __ ] respond to
this all right we're at the end of the
podcast here people I can't set
something up and not have it follow
through desperate times desperate
measures
here we go come on I'm calling her I
feel like oh no morning like zoo show
right now we're gonna collar it work it
see what happens
that's two rings did you get my last
text the voicemail that voicemail I've
read both of those on the podcast and
the listeners who evidently liked you
more than me want to hear your response
all right think of a good one sweetie
cuz I'm ending the podcast on it alright
no pressure
we either end with the laugh or you get
blamed what I just read you I just read
your text man I said oh look at this
text message I go I'm not even in the
house she's still telling me what the
[ __ ] to do oh this should be a good one
there should be a good one what the [ __ ]
did she say to me I had my son's son hat
on today I just put it on my head cuz I
knew it'd be funny but I was also I had
a bunch of this [ __ ] in my hand and she
goes she looked like what she said she'd
said I look like an egg with something
on top it was [ __ ] really mean but
this is this is how I my belief I think
I'm a [ __ ] how mean it is if it's funny
then you gotta laugh at it right night
somebody was getting trashed on the
internet she told me one of the things
that they called her and I started I
just roared laughing she's like how
could you hit that I'm like come on it's
[ __ ] hilarious
who's trolling you [ __ ] Archie Bunker
who says that anymore anyway
no it wasn't racial it was anti-semitic
alright come on Nia the fans are waiting
alright one of these days you know when
our life settles down in about ten years
I'm gonna have her on and discuss that
[ __ ] green bag
come on sweet Jesus Christ how [ __ ]
long does it take I'm gonna I'm gonna
give her a fun
Nia we're waiting how [ __ ] long do
you need to tell me to go [ __ ] myself
all right send I hope you guys
appreciate this this could turn into a
real one All Right see the goal here was
that she would just send it right back
to me I could end the [ __ ] podcast
and then I could [ __ ] in my garage
slash office [ __ ] work on my Bonham
triplets that's what I wanted to do then
I was gonna have an Ice Cream Sandwich
before I go to bed Oh God
40 seconds people okay here we go press
and play Jesus Christ
[Music]
okay there's no [ __ ] way we ended on
that sacrifice your body sacrifice your
body collectively for 18 months what are
you gonna do to my wallet for the next
[ __ ] 44 years combined I will not be
sending that okay you know people every
once in a while you know if you're a
smart married guy you gotta let him win
she didn't even come with humor Jesus
Christ I think she just tried to [ __ ]
me to me all right I'm gonna leave all
of these well you just took all the fun
out of it oh my god
okay that was stupid I was I was I was
away from I was in the [ __ ] garage
there's supposed to be my safe space and
what did i do i [ __ ] the whole thing up
i should have just taken the gun
completely ignored that i [ __ ] put a
tape gun worth it tape around the
[ __ ] thing was in the frig you
couldn't even smell it [ __ ] thinking
of smell in the goddamn look at me now
I'm talking to myself it's unbelievable
that's unbelievable but you know you got
to love them how's your wife doing is
she doing okay you know that's what they
do yeah check in with the idiot
I'm good to everybody don't [ __ ]
worry about this [ __ ] cauliflower it
worked myself during early grave of
Jesus is she [ __ ] scented something
else to me audio message oh here we go
audio message what does it say audio
message okay now I should be old enough
not to engage but I'm going to hey
dum-dum I told you I [ __ ] took out a
tape gun I actually put it in the trash
at first opened I was like wait it's
gonna stink up the kitchen so I put a
[ __ ] I took out the tape gun and went
around the thing it's it's sealed
alright
we're lap but I'll go in there I'll
[ __ ] throw it out alright you just
[ __ ] sit there and rest up okay
watching you you're you're watching
those [ __ ] [ __ ] selling those
houses oh there we go alright that'll do
it we'll leave it at that
[ __ ] it got him [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know it's [ __ ] I believe when the
[ __ ] do they ever give it up I love that
whole thing I sacrifice my body no you
had unprotected sex is what you did and
then nature took over stop acting like
you're doing something you just lay in
there letting it happen
woof
thank God I didn't send that on a voice
text all right let's get the [ __ ] out
here thank you so much for listening
please enjoy them music picked out by
the great end with emili´s there'll be
another bonus bonus bonus bonus half
hour of material from a Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast at Grace hits other
episode and that is it have a great
weekend you [ __ ] and I'll see you on
Monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Phil Byrne it's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday
July 11th 2012 how are you what's going
on
I got a ton of [ __ ] to do tomorrow walk
yourselves I gotta go to the airport so
I'm doing this Sunday night you know
doing all the pre airport stuff wash the
dishes wash my [ __ ] socks and
underwear I'm ready to go you know I've
had a great [ __ ] weekend I don't want
to go on the road you know if you think
I want to get on another [ __ ] Tweety
Bird and go fly to some godforsaken
strip mall in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere which is basically the middle of
nowhere to me at this point is anywhere
that is not near my house you know hey
come to Chicago what [ __ ] no we're
talking about these 2nd largest states
in the Union what union is that sir the
North American and [ __ ] away from me
you're an agent freemason
isn't it amazing how you can't talk me
trying to adjust yourself you just yeah
that old person sounds you know trying
to [ __ ] readjust your man tits I've
been working out I work out
wiggle-wiggle-wiggle will douche I've
been I am let's let's let's let's bring
it down a little bit let's bring the
tone down a little bit let's just ease
it on in you know you're sitting there
coming down from the sugar rush from
that [ __ ] curly you shouldn't eatin
that bear claw right what else did you
have what do you have the thing at the
airport what do they got there the big
[ __ ] uh you know we look like it
looked like a diabetic took a [ __ ]
whatever they call a Cinnabon a lot of
people don't know that that's that's
where they that's where they get their
dough from as when a real fat person
takes a [ __ ] they that's when you that's
when you know you have to lose weight is
when you just [ __ ] a Cinnabon and you
didn't you you knew didn't eat one it's
not like you went straight through your
system okay it's that it's just an
amalgam of that is the waste of what you
ate that day you know something is it my
goal to lose every female on this
podcast any feat remote female listener
it's almost like this subconscious self
self-sabotage I'm two minutes forty
seconds into this [ __ ] thing and you
know I got to put that visual out there
you know I probably lost not only all of
the women I lost some guys who are like
in touch with their feelings anybody's
remotely a human being so now now it's
just uh now it's just us it's just the
sociopaths let's just let them slowly
quote you know file out of the room I
thought it was gonna be something
different I did too
I like sweets I don't [ __ ] in a bunch
sorry I said the S word
um my [ __ ] dog Cleo I want your life
you know what is your biggest decision
what room am I gonna lay down and go
down and [ __ ] go to sleep in is that
what it is I got a [ __ ] spider web of
my the remnants of a spider web I can't
figure out all the spiders in my house
like me or they don't like me you know
cuz I kind of let them be when it gets a
little ridiculous you know the size of
the spider webs because I figured that
they're here for a reason that must mean
I have other bugs here and they're gonna
kill them so like I look at them like
they're my like insect police
you know and I'm the rich guy cuz isn't
that what the what do you call the
[ __ ] policeman our isn't that why
they initially came about was to protect
the rich people's stuff just in case
everybody working form was like eh
how much is that vase worth their
[ __ ] what's a rich guy's name Hg
[ __ ] [ __ ] face don't you know that we
set those names back then not the [ __ ]
face part but they always had the
initials right you know HG Rockefeller
JD Rockefeller you know JP Morgan JP man
man I don't care if kids put my shoes
again yeah alright they all talk like
Edward G Robinson for some reason thirty
years before even [ __ ] was famous come
on bill get your [ __ ] together
I have a sugar rush right now I had
[ __ ] spaghetti again Pet it four times
this [ __ ] week that's what happens
when all your recipes that you got from
your parents are for like ten people you
know and it's just you and your goddamn
dog whatever you're making you know you
make sketti you're gonna be eating that
for [ __ ] two weeks I got [ __ ]
octopus coming on my [ __ ] nose here
that was a Sopranos version of Tony
Montana case you were wondering
Danny is out of town again this week you
know I think she's slowly breaking up
with me via vacations you know just sort
of easing me into what it's gonna be
like when she's not here and I gotta
tell you I'm doing fine you know I can't
[ __ ] do the laundry I can't make
spaghetti ten times in a week I don't
need you Jesus what'd you do with your
weekend bill well I had too much to
drink Friday night and I'm back on the
wagon you know back on the [ __ ] wagon
I don't think I think this is an old
give me that old joke will they say I'm
not an alcoholic I just drink like one
that that's me
you don't mean I'm one of those guys if
I'm gonna have a pizza I'm gonna eat the
whole [ __ ] thing I'm not saving some
for later in
maybe having it for breakfast and then
talk about sports on ESPN
alright then they have a show called
cold pizza with skip bayless was always
losing his [ __ ] about something do you
guys buy you guys buy that guy
do you buy his outrage you know I mean I
think his outrage is about as believable
as ice cubes anger Ice Cube has had the
exact same scowl on his face from NWA
all the way to these cores like
commercials it is the exact he is the
exact same look on his face when he was
talking about the man as he does when
beer bottles take over his studio you
know maybe he's just straight across the
board angry god knows I can relate to
that but there's certain people would
after a while you got to be like dude
you gotta have another emotion in there
don't you skip bayless is another guy I
don't give a [ __ ] if you said a you need
air to breathe he would somehow argue
the other side put his eyebrows up near
his [ __ ] game show host hair that he
has you know is that his hair it's got
to be his hair either that or he went to
like he got a do they make weaves for
white guys you know if they made weaves
to white guys everybody would want skip
bayless is here I get it if it came in
some sort of some sort of red I'd get
one I get one in a second I'd be hot
that summer though you know that's why
I'd never get a [ __ ] toupee you know
just sit now with your full head of
[ __ ] hair just slapped on there like
a shingle scalp sweating underneath it
you know what the [ __ ] am i doing you
know and then what at night I come home
and I take it off and I just look at my
father just look at the landed strip on
top of my head right where where you
know the rest of my face got you son and
then this I got this blind you know what
I would I would look like the globe you
know
on top of my head would be like the
North Pole you know my chest would be
the South Pole and then my face would be
the tropics that basically it I mean
it's basically the climates you know my
nose would be some sort of mountain
range coming down from [ __ ] Alaska
why do you guys listen to this stupid
punk ass anyways so oh I didn't tell you
this I got a [ __ ] I got a I got I
bought one of those those giant green
eggs to [ __ ] I bought one the ugliest
[ __ ] sin but they are the [ __ ] this
is not an advertising this is a freebie
alright people over at the Big Green Egg
in case you sell half a one
I love the goddamn thing it looks like
an unripe avocado it's one of the
ugliest things you've ever seen in your
life okay but they got a couple of
gaskets they got a seal here it's a seal
here and you run it up the alley no I
made some burgers and dogs that's what I
did first and then there was this
barbecue place that was going out of
business or relocating I don't know what
was happening but all I know was all
their [ __ ] was was half off so I went
down there and I got the thing for
[ __ ] ribs right not baby back either
the [ __ ] the good ones you know you
just lay the [ __ ] right over there
okay doing ribs isn't even that hard
though this [ __ ] douchebags you see
on on the Food Channel talking about all
the [ __ ] that they do and they sitting
there with their little [ __ ] baster
hey what do you do you slather it with
some [ __ ] that's taste good you stick it
in the [ __ ] thing and then you come
back four hours later and you go oh
would you look at that Oh would you look
at that falling right off the boat right
and then they eat it and then they
always tell you it's good well of course
you're gonna say that it's your [ __ ]
cooking show have you ever seen in a
cooking show where guy took a bite was
like ah goddamn it I overcooked it dried
that [ __ ] out well you know you win some
you lose some
come on back next week folks maybe I
won't cook the [ __ ] out of this salmon
they never say that they always eat you
know it's like and they always eat it
too and they're like running out of time
so before they take half a bite they go
oh I wish you could take you didn't even
[ __ ] chew it you know what that's
like that's in in the acting profession
I learned this when I did Glee that's
called playing the end of the scene you
don't I mean like if you you know if you
read like your whole scene you have to
audition for right it's basically you're
your character walks into a rental car
place you're supposed to have a [ __ ]
rental car they don't have it then you
flip out and you yell right and in the
end there's a big [ __ ] yelling
[ __ ] right the inexperienced actor
comes in already [ __ ] amped up it's
like why you're already amped up you're
walking and expecting the [ __ ] car to
be there
you wouldn't already be mad you're
playing the end of the scene that's what
those [ __ ] do on the Food Network
because they're running out of time
Oh [ __ ] Suzy mother and hips there
whatever the [ __ ] name is who I said
I'd like to bang her before she
highlighted her hair and did the whole
[ __ ] JLo thing where she toned down
her [ __ ] brunette ish look on her
face you know what I mean what's her
name Rachael Ray Rachael Ray did the
exact same make over that [ __ ] JLo
did both of them where were brunettes
brown eyes big bushy [ __ ] eyebrows
they did the same goddamn thing they
[ __ ] they thin that [ __ ] out they
threw a little throw a little Sun in
their hair right and all of a sudden oh
wow look at you jumping off the page you
know you don't want to do an
overcorrection though you don't know
overcorrect brunette if you overcorrect
brunette you go right past blonde and
into redhead and then that's a slippery
slope into albino and in the you not get
no one's gonna see your [ __ ] movie or
watch you make some french dip alright
so I'm not making fun of the profession
that that's a very delicate process to
take someone who has brown too much
brown you know and they gotta lighten
them up in the eyebrow hair area but
what I always think because I'm a
[ __ ] pervert is it's like alright you
[ __ ] you know you dialed in the Sun
up top what happened down bottom you
don't to me cuz if your eyebrows are
that [ __ ] bushy what in God's name is
going down there
going on down there and you in the
slacks area did you get that highlighted
is that gonna match you know am I going
to see who you really are when your
droids hit the floor sweetheart
well that was a fun first [ __ ] 15
minutes wasn't it
how oh hey guess who's advertising this
this this week guess who's back it's our
old friends at ProFlowers remember them
way back on Mother's Day remember them
on Valentine's Day well now they're
hitting us up every month they want you
to buy flowers every month and I know
what you're thinking what I don't know
but it's up to me is the pitchman that I
have to some they have to somehow come
up with an angle I got to come up with
an angle here this is what you got to do
okay
and I actually do this okay so this is
coming from my heart not from the wallet
all right this isn't the magic bullet
here this is coming straight up all
right didn't make a right turn down to
my ass right to my wallet it didn't okay
every once in a while every once in a
while oh wait Cleo shifting she's
shifting and she's stretching and then
that's it she didn't get him you look
like a little pig you know that little
wild boar Cleo
those thighs on you do you do squats
when I'm not looking is that what you're
so tired from all the time anyways
ProFlowers everybody it's July 4th you
could have given some to Uncle Sam last
week but it's too late for that now is
that the original goatee by the way
Uncle Sam Uncle Sam looks like an old
retired like NBA player from the 70s but
somehow he's white by then by then
whitey was was getting pushed out of the
league wasn't he all right let's get
back to the advertising here ProFlowers
ProFlowers it's July it's July you know
what this is what you got you're in a
relationship every once in a while just
I don't know where you got to give him
some flowers
you know okay you know is it ever a
wrong time to give your mother some
flowers are you gonna go visit them do
you have a mother-in-law who just looks
at you like why did you marry my
daughter you know give her some flowers
maybe she'll lighten up either way if
you get a big enough arrangement you
have to look at her stupid face across
the tea the table when you sit down to
eat you know if you don't like somebody
what better way to block their stupid
face than to go out and get a bunch of
flowers at proflowers.com just click on
the microphone in the upper right hand
corner you type in the password birbee
URR and they'll get the vase they'll
stick him in the wall and they'll send
it to that person love him or not send
them flowers and that's the end and the
dismount
oh speaking and the dismount you know I
was telling you that I was starting to
put on weight again Oh Billy fat again
you know Billy McFadden and I decided
that I was gonna halt that and I was
going to turn this bus around and try to
get myself back in shape and I've been
doing all all body weight stuff climbing
the rope I'm doing the pull-ups I'm
doing the dip Shh I'm doing what else
you got there whatever that I don't do
chin up so chin ups are for girls
pull-ups affirm n all right
in fact yeah I remember we went Demi
Moore played that chick who got our head
buzzed down GI Jane right she wasn't
doing chin up she was doing pull-ups cuz
she was a marine right I think that was
not the message of that movie what was
the message of that movie other than men
are horrific
what is the guy version of that movie
like like hot dog and when those those
tetanus movies they used to make when
you first got cable Oh about ski bunnies
and the same premise and now they're on
the beach and that always be chicks like
just taking their tops off like that
happens you know maybe it happens on the
French Riviera I don't know but then
they got hairy armpits there's always
something to balance it out people it's
the yin and the yang you know I just
completely forgot what I was talking
about I was talking about pull-ups
that's right so so I don't know if you
guys Melissa how long I listen to
podcasts I [ __ ] up my abdomen on the
right side about five years ago I was at
a Pittsburgh Pirates game I was one of
the few and I was there and I was drunk
as always alcohol always playing a role
and I was drunk I was drunk building and
I was with Paul Varzi who said good I
[ __ ] cold
look at the bridge I said it iced when
they made this ballpark I said you know
what they're gonna do they're gonna have
it where you can see the bridge from the
from from the home-plate looking right
on there it is I thought you're not
taking this one away from me you're not
saying I called it oh look at the bridge
by the lightweight I love when you guys
send me tweets or Twitter's whatever the
[ __ ] you call them when whenever
Robinson Cano does something and you
make fun of Rosie that always makes me
laugh
like Cano will get a double Mersey
called it he called it he called it
I'm Paul virzi do you want to be the guy
who calls it Welch all you need is my
dude I called it system number one
[ __ ] call everything think about it
if you call everything eventually
something that you said will happen then
what you do is you yell about it you
continue to yell about it hopefully
until everybody forgets everything else
that you called that did not happen
you know it is at this point the fact
that virzi still talks about his call
that robinson cano
was gonna be a hall of fame he watched
him like [ __ ] three weeks and said
this guy is gonna be a hall-of-famer
evidently okay which is absolutely
asinine okay unless you like Ted
Williams unless you're really a guy in
baseball you can you can look at those
things all right virzi is one of those
guys he wants to be the guy who said it
first so he just says [ __ ] first you
know like if he was on The Price is
Right there's no way he would pass the
first showcase he wouldn't he would bid
on it because he wouldn't want that
other person to bid before he did that's
what he would do
did that make any sense I don't give a
[ __ ] so anyways I've been working out
that's what the [ __ ] I'm trying to talk
about so this is I [ __ ] up my abdomen
all right I was I was at the was with
this other comic Doug sing yay I was at
Paul Varzi and myself I think Doug's
brother right we were all having a good
time drinking some beers right we're all
talking [ __ ] his old guys do and next
thing you know I'm trying to show them
that I can go into the pike position
hammered alright so I put my [ __ ]
hand on one seat and then won another
seat lift myself up and then I bring my
legs straight out in front of me like I
had been doing but I'm old I didn't
stretch I don't know what happened right
and then later on the night I remember
being drunk and somebody we would skip
and rope on a sidewalk and I had like a
45 degree [ __ ] angle across from his
place where a bunch of drunks were
getting food I felt a life of me I don't
know where we got the [ __ ] jump rope
I don't know where we got it I think
somebody there had it from the gym and
then that's what it became that's why
when it became because I actually
[ __ ] went into the pipe position so
then they will I can [ __ ] skip rope
typical guys [ __ ] alright and I know
this bugs the ladies but you know
something that's why there's air
conditioning
okay that's why because of that [ __ ]
because that's how we're geared I can do
this well I can do this well I can do
that [ __ ] better right and next thing
you know you got wall-to-wall carpeting
I
right so shut your face and make me a
sandwich anyways so the next morning I
wake up and I don't it feels it felt
like somebody took some sort of medieval
like if that Freddy Krueger glove dipped
it in fire and then [ __ ] a raked
right down the right side of me so for
years I've been babying it finally and
one time I went and I got I got ralt I
believe which is a really deep [ __ ]
massage and was really weird it was the
only person I found although who's
kidding who the first person I found I
just clicked on that I went to that that
person's place and I went there and
ended up being a guy doing it and it was
really [ __ ] weird it was just weird I
was like we've done yet no no no we
still got more you got to do the other
side but I think that's alright
did it help I don't [ __ ] know so you
know what I finally just said I finally
said I finally said is that homophobic
by the way that I will only go to a girl
to get a [ __ ] massage unless I'm
really hurt you know if I'm really
[ __ ] hurt and I'm just so [ __ ]
like time I jacked up my shoulder I just
don't give a [ __ ] and just like just
make the pain go away is that homophobic
you know I bet if a woman did it was
like you know I I don't want well she
would say I only want a girl alright so
I'm a little homophobic go [ __ ]
yourselves I got issues so anyways so I
finally I finally just said you know
what why don't I just try pushing
through the paint why don't I stop being
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] just push through
the paint so you know you know those
those little wheels with the handles on
them I just started doing that I do ten
reps a day I wouldn't go too far you
know in like a week the whole paints
gone gone away so you know me I can't be
like I will [ __ ] it now now I feel good
is that good enough for bill no now I'm
on YouTube trying to learn how to do the
human flag that [ __ ] 44 years old I'm
literally going down the street to a
stop sign doing my little the little
side things
trying to build up the strength for what
for what purpose bill you know you got
your health you your core feels good
again why are you gonna go down there
and just blow something else out you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know you gonna be
right back on a table getting massaged
by a dude alright whatever
it's what the [ __ ] I do so this weekend
Nia's been away and so I got this big
green [ __ ] egg thing and I got the
the dddd dddd the table that came with
it and it took like a [ __ ] month by
the way to get that thing you know I got
I got the table where the egg sits in it
cuz I hate that [ __ ] when you [ __ ]
barbecue and they give you that little
those two little looks like those trays
that you know that you haven't like an
airplane you just set them down on both
sides and that's supposed to take you
home
you know all the meat and then where do
I hang the [ __ ] spatula I don't need
that [ __ ] alright
that guy he's gonna die in jail I don't
need that [ __ ] ok ain't happening to me
hey you stop dealing that [ __ ] you know
something I watch Goodfellas the other
day and I think I think what the [ __ ]
his name that I I'm starting like him
the best in that movie the [ __ ] his
name
Paulie Paul Sorvino I loved I loved that
[ __ ] thing when he told him not to
deal drugs and he's telling how that
guy's gonna die in jail ok that ain't
happened to me and stupid sweaty piece
of [ __ ] and Rahill the [ __ ] rat by
the way I didn't get when when the real
Henry Hill died why people like they
kind of confused their love of that
movie and kind of forgot that this guy
ratted out all his friends you know I
mean if that movie's accurate right I
mean I know he ratted out his friends
but I don't know if that's the exact
reason why I did was it because he was
[ __ ] dealing drugs was there a guy
saying don't do it am I going to keep
asking questions so anyways I get this
table for this [ __ ] thing and you
know it comes comes here like a newborn
baby
[ __ ] naked right it's got new fun
it's not stained it's got nothing on it
right so I gotta I gotta deal with all
that [ __ ] I've been doing that the
whole [ __ ] weekend and doing it the
right way too by the way I stained on
top and the bottom I know a lot of you
weekend warriors yeah you're like [ __ ]
that ain't doing that nobody looks under
there do it if any water gets on that
part of the [ __ ] table the whole
thing's gonna be under grab your under
water I'll go [ __ ] yourself I did the
whole thing two coats when Friday one
Saturday and then today I did the
[ __ ] the varnish and I got to tell
you man that's a [ __ ] of a job it's
just tedious [ __ ] TD especially if
you do the underneath - I'm sitting
there laying on my back like [ __ ]
Fonzarelli you know just [ __ ] laying
there working on this [ __ ] and I tell
you a lot of times I was going to tap
out and just be like you know what I'm
not gonna do this the right way I'm just
gonna do this stuff the [ __ ] way and
I didn't and I was happy I was proud of
myself and you know what I'm gonna show
it to Nia and I'm telling you I if she
[ __ ] says why did you pick that color
why didn't you do this color right I'm
gonna take what's left of that [ __ ]
stain and I'm gonna dump it over I would
never do that
you know what I'll do it to myself will
become the martyr and then we'll see
what she has to say so anyways I got
this [ __ ] egg and I'm gonna make ribs
and all this [ __ ] and somehow still be
able to do the human flag as I'm gonna
[ __ ] I don't know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna buy like a [ __ ] bison off
of ebay and freeze that son of a [ __ ]
and cooking slow cooker for the rest of
the summer and that's gonna be it I'm
gonna get fat girl's gonna get fat my
dogs gonna get fat and I'm gonna have a
whole new hour material and what a tub
of [ __ ] I am that's how great that thing
is all right let's plow ahead with the
podcast everybody if you're new to the
podcast and you would like to send me an
email if there's a topic you'd like me
to discuss go off on it for your
possibly you want to give me [ __ ] you're
probably saying bill where the [ __ ] do I
do that you
go to bill at the mm podcast.com that's
where you email me bill at the capital m
capital m capital p odd cast com
alright that's it and Oh before I get
into this [ __ ] I'm gonna be in
Washington DC tomorrow night not too RI
Tuesday night at the DC improv
celebrating their 30 years in the
business by telling my dick and [ __ ]
jokes and then this weekend I will be at
Hampton Beach in New Hampshire Hampton
Beach ballroom casino one of my favorite
venues that I do Led Zeppelin played
they're one of the few small venues that
they played on they're quick little tea
party tour that they did before they
just blew up and then I'll be at the
Newport yachting Center in Newport Rhode
Island I know that sounds fancy but I
swear to God it's an air-conditioned
tent in a parking lot you know when you
walk out the tent you can see a bunch of
yachts but I'm not on one it sounds good
though all right okay here we go first
one first one out of the gate validation
sons mother is a nut job this is coming
for my nut job that's a nice coat dude
she's a [ __ ] nut job all right dear
Billy Boy did I just [ __ ] this thing up
come on come on I need life here here we
go all right dear Billy Boy a couple
months ago I split up but with my son's
mother we weren't married so I basically
packed my [ __ ] up and my son stuff and
moved out we hadn't been get it we
hadn't been getting along for a while
because she didn't help me out with our
son and was texting all the time that's
what she was doing she was texting all
the time and she's probably talking to
the other guy she's probably [ __ ] I'm
sorry did me to put that out there um
the night before I moved out I received
the text talking about treating her
better than I did I asked to see her
phone and she wouldn't let me so I moved
out the next day and she spent the night
with some dude that same night I moved
out yeah dude let me tell you something
right now if your girl isn't paying
attention to you and she's texting all
the time she's talking to the dick that
she's riding
okay so unless yours is vibrating
she ate texting you alright
no okay um anyways next night the next
night this guy started living with her
Jesus Christ yeah so she had a full-on
relationship going on the side so we
were pretty much through but a couple
weeks later it was Mother's Day and she
told me what my son wanted me to get her
my son is two years old and doesn't
really talk a whole lot so she was
telling me what she wanted
I told her to go [ __ ] herself because I
wasn't getting her [ __ ] there you go
good for you she told me that she was
still the mother of my child and I
should get her something Jesus Christ is
this people who use that kind of guilt
who you actually use like the children
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
anyways also I had paid the rent right
before I moved out and when I found out
this guy was staring staying there the
night I moved out I cancelled the rent
check and also got my name off the lease
whoa there's a nice one too to the
[ __ ] jawbone I know I did the right
thing please tell me that you agree that
this chick is [ __ ] up in the head too
oh and since I moved out she sees our
son 1 or 2 days a week tops so to me
she's a shitty mother who didn't deserve
and didn't deserve a gift go [ __ ]
yourself PS when you come into the
Kansas City area alright um well
granite I just heard your side of the
story but uh yeah sounds like the way
the picture you're painting there sir
absolutely look the fact that the day
you move out she bangs another guy and
then the other person moves in I mean I
think he got a good I think you got a
good that's uh there was nothing but
victory in there as far as I see you
didn't marry her you didn't love her you
knocked her up you toughed it out you
tried to do the right thing there was no
love there to sustain it in the end and
in the end she was doing what she wanted
to do she was trying to find love
somewhere else and she's probably
relieved that you're gone I will tell
you this so the fact that you have a kid
with her she's gonna be in your life for
at least another 16 years until his kids
18 years old so she could make your life
really [ __ ] miserable don't ask me
how I don't know they find a way it's
what they do
so you know that this one you're right
if she gives you [ __ ] just do that
listen I move out and that night you
bang another guy and the next day you
know the guy moved in okay I can do the
math am I really supposed to sit here
and believe that you didn't have a
relationship going on while we were
still together and then you want me to
go out and buy you a [ __ ] flow be
really is that what you're telling me
well screaming into you [ __ ] cuz I'm not
listening come on um surprise we're
getting a divorce all right here's a new
story all right hey Bill I know you have
you aren't a therapist but I think I
just want to talk to anyone at this
point
so here goes I've been married for just
under four years to my wife who I dated
for four years prior to marriage I loved
being married and I've said that to
anyone that asked since day one we owned
a nice house together we have three dogs
pit bulls - good man and both make a
decent living I share everything in my
life with my wife when something makes
me happy she knows when I'm upset about
something I tell her throughout the
course of our relationship about once a
year she would suddenly without warning
say she she was unhappy and has been for
months okay here we go
she says she has discussions with her
mom who loves me and is the sweetest
woman alive and close friends about the
things that make her unhappy but I never
hear a word about it until it boils over
and she floors me with how unhappy she
is well that's not fair all right we
tried to work it out though make changes
she would act like it was okay while it
bottling it up again once once the lid
goes on the bottle there's no opening
and again each and every time she calls
the unhappiness State of the Union
meeting into session
I've always been completely honest as
saying that I'm very happy with her I
love our jokes and honesty and honestly
enjoy spending time bah bah bah Jesus
Christ dude
to the [ __ ] point alright last
Wednesday here we go we had a good night
together we went out for dinner and ice
cream and laughed at about
abba-baba-baba so I thought I'd come
home
the following night in general great
mood and she told me she had talked to
her mom and a friend and that they
recommend that she talked to me I was
confused and then well [ __ ] about not
being unhappy uh anyways I wanted
anything to make her happy but she told
me she didn't think there was anything
it was very emotional as she finally
mustered up the courage to say that we
might need to get separated I was
floored and not in an I'm an [ __ ]
husband that sits around drinks beer and
watches football with his buddy way I
love my wife we have free okay dude okay
okay okay okay so the following day
after much reluctance I get her to agree
to try marriage counseling so we can
work out our happiness dude I'm not
giving you [ __ ] that this is you're
pouring your heart out because this [ __ ]
just happen I understand but for the
sake of the listeners I gotta fly
through this I get to agree with her I
get to I get it okay
so the following day it's like Lord of
the Rings here after much reluctance I
get her to agree to try marriage
counseling so we can work out her
unhappiness I was willing to do anything
at this point
I immediately scheduled an appointment
with the counselor and I was looking
forward to having someone neutral for us
to talk to later that night we were
laying in bed and I asked her if there
was someone else in her life she said no
a dude Jesus I love Jesus ah Jesus here
we go
we just went over the waterfall folks or
were we you know it is no no in this
story we're hearing the waterfall and
we've just looked at the other person in
the raft with a panicked look on her
face for that split second before we try
to desperately but futile II try and
paddle the [ __ ] thing over to the
goddamn coast okay here we go
we're going over I got a feeling we're
going over she said no there's no one
else in my life
I asked if she's ever been unfaithful in
our relationship relationship and she
Adam at least said no again then she
turned out the light and laid down to
sleep five minutes later she sat up
and turn the light on oh [ __ ] she told
me she just lied to me and said that she
had messed around with someone a year
into our marriage and he writes in
capital letters what period the period
[ __ ] period I probed her to tell me what
messing around was that's gotta at least
be a [ __ ] and after a minute of me
guessing her silence told me that she
went down on a guy she works with swear
to God I hadn't read this oh if I was
virzi right now dude what you heard me
you heard me with the FIR [ __ ] creep
I was furious and hurt then furious
again she cried and cried and said she
was sorry we cried together dude you're
a bigger man than me
while I tried to wrap my head around how
she could possibly have done that to me
I've had casual flirting with people
over the years but to act on something
physically with someone other than your
spouse is completely disgusting to me
the worst part is I love this woman more
than anyone she's been my ah here we go
again she's gonna be the best friend for
the last eight years she knows
everything about me I want to hate her
and make her sleep at her parents house
until we divorce but all I want to do is
be near her again yeah dude that's
because yeah dude
she was in the hurry up offense that's
what happened here so now your scamper
and trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
is going on and she you know she has the
next three place that she just called in
the huddle that's why this this is why
it sucks to be you right now one of my
close friends tells me what I know is
the right thing he goes let it go don't
bother with clown selling what else has
she done that you don't know about how
he never trust her again bill is it
possible for me to forgive my wife am I
wasting my time also I find out who this
guy is
and I really wish I hadn't yeah I do of
course all I wanted to to do was show up
at the job beat the [ __ ] out of him like
Ed Norton beats the blonde pretty boy up
in Fight Club he writes I wanted to
destroy something beautiful
my other thought is since this guy also
cheated on his girlfriend who was still
with my he did it with my wife I
threatened to tell his girlfriend what
he'd done but not actually do it yeah
you don't wanna do that that way he'd
live in fear of coming home and her
knowing everything because I told her or
he would try to beat me to it admit to
it hopefully ending his relationship and
getting terminal cancer and AIDS
terminal cancer and AIDS and you know
what you still being a gentleman I still
think that you're handling this with
class wishing terminal cancer and AIDS
on this guy I know you don't give a [ __ ]
of course I give a [ __ ] but not occupy
uh but I've got to occupy my mind so I
thought I'd do it here yeah dude why
would you think I don't give a [ __ ] you
know I mean I'm not a friend of yours
but you know what I mean give me a
[ __ ] break this is horrific all right
your first question bill is it possible
for me to forgive my wife eventually
you're gonna have to and lor you're
gonna go on a [ __ ] tear and you're
gonna meet some really damaged [ __ ]
women and they're gonna reinforce
everything that you've now found out
about your wife so you can't do that
you're gonna go on a [ __ ] hate [ __ ]
[ __ ] spree that is yeah you don't want
to do that he said am I wasting my time
yeah dude it's over she's not happy
she's not good at communicating she puts
a lid on it you know until it boils over
this is the deal dude you know what I
this is gonna kill you all right let's
go with the positive you don't have any
kids with her okay you can just walk
away okay we had a problem and there was
there's nothing we can do
Dover they didn't make it you just
[ __ ] walk away just walk away it's
over all right that's a good thing all
right the one thing you've had a bunch
of kids with this [ __ ] this person
who for whatever reason couldn't say
that they were I don't think that she
want even wanted to [ __ ] marry you
I think she ignores her feelings
she's actually having a [ __ ]
breakthrough right now while stomping
all over your [ __ ] heart all right
well I don't know I don't know I don't
[ __ ] her
give me a break dude you [ __ ] you
loved her with all your heart you say
your mother's a sweetheart you got dogs
you like communicating dude you know
something you're like the [ __ ] guy
you're the guy my girl wants me to be
every [ __ ] woman wants a guy like
that you know guy who actually wants to
be married guy who actually comes home
and communicates you know a guy who gets
along with the mom and all that type of
[ __ ] you're a family man all right
unfortunately you know you met the wrong
person so [ __ ] forget that dude all
right forget it forget it [ __ ] that [ __ ]
dad it's over walk away walk away dude
give me a [ __ ] about you you know what
you're talking about that you're talking
about like the amount of [ __ ] [ __ ]
she has to go through before she even
learns how to just communicate her
[ __ ] emotions and the frustration of
that's gonna mean every once in a while
she's gonna blow somebody at work are
you wasting your time
abso-fucking-lutely
okay abso-fucking-lutely and as far as
like going there and trying to [ __ ] over
that other guy that other guy is he's
already you don't need to [ __ ] him over
he's [ __ ] himself over he's living at
the he's living a life of misery that
life is miserable to [ __ ] around with
the person that you with with somebody
else that is a miserable life you know I
don't know I think it's something that a
lot of guys do myself included back in
the day and my 20s going into 30s trying
to [ __ ] you know figure myself out I
lived that life that whole [ __ ]
double it's horrible it's a [ __ ]
horrible thing and in the end I ended up
alone and I heard a lot of people and I
was a complete piece of [ __ ] so and
believe me dude it was miserable it
ended up me if me on a [ __ ] futon
so yeah do yo your you know don't become
a piece of [ __ ] now don't judge other
women like that just [ __ ] you know
yeah get out of it get out of it and
just know that it's gonna be a [ __ ] I
don't know it's gonna be a hundred yards
of pain that you never [ __ ] dealt with
in your life and you just got to go
through it and I would say the next time
you get with somebody make you know
you're gonna get serious with somebody
you make goddamn sure that they know how
to [ __ ] communicate because that's
that's a scary thing to get with a woman
who does not to communicate because
that's something that they're supposed
to teach us how to do you know in a way
they make you better because yo I can
just say no I don't feel like doing that
without [ __ ] punching the wall you
know they do that sort of sell you down
if you get with some psycho and she
can't settle you down I mean she's she's
damaged goods dude all right here we go
next one these things just keep getting
deeper asexual this is from a plant or
something dear billion uh this is a bit
of change from the emails you usually
get but I hope you can help me out
anyways I'm a 26 year old guy completely
normal in every way except for one I'm
asexual for your listeners who don't
know what that means it means I don't
feel any sexual desires at all I never
have take a moment to wrap your head
around that one I think I'm gonna need
more than a moment dude let me ask you
this what do you do with all your free
time you know how many [ __ ] languages
can you speak
everything about that how much [ __ ]
[ __ ] you would get done if you weren't
chasing at all the goddamn time
alright uh but believe it or not I do
have a girlfriend we've been together
for four years
so what do you do to get aroused think
about like when it's over I'm really
being a dick right now I'm sorry buh he
goes and before that we were friends for
about another five years we both helped
each other through some rough [ __ ] and
eventually decided that we wanted to be
more than friends she's the first girl
I've ever known who made me wish I
wasn't a say sexual
knew all about it when we started dating
so there were no surprises in fact she's
been really cool we joked about it a lot
and when we did have sex which was once
or twice a month I did everything I
couldn't make it good for this is like
fascinating so like what are you
thinking of you know three more minutes
she should be happy row row row your
boat gently down the stream
but lately things have been different it
wasn't a sudden change but something I
just noticed recently she doesn't joke
around about sex as much as she used to
and we now have sex once every 2 or 3
months our emotional bond is still as
strong as ever in fact just last week we
were talking about marriage but I have a
feeling my gut that she might be [ __ ]
another guy I know her well enough to
know that having sex four times a year
is nowhere near enough for her the thing
is it wouldn't bother me if she was
[ __ ] someone else I know she has
needs that I can't fulfill so I'd be
willing to have a pinch-hitter come in
and get the job done for me Jesus talk
about a [ __ ] 180 from the last story
I just sorry I had to pause and do the
math and just make sure that I didn't
say that the wrong number sometimes it
was a total 360 no that was a 180 I just
wanted I just want to know about it I've
wanted to ask her about it but I'm
worried about what will happen if I'm
wrong what should I do
I love this girl to get death and I
never forgive myself if I [ __ ] up a good
thing we have together ah dude that's
outside my totally outside my bounds I
don't know what to tell you
I would I would start going to therapy
[Music]
alone first and then possibly bring her
in but you know that's I I don't I don't
know anything about I don't know
anything about being asexual so that
that would be my advice you know if you
want to fix that problem in that type of
thing but I don't know I feel like I let
you down dude I'm sorry but I'm not
gonna sit here and [ __ ] run my Yap
like I mean I don't know the [ __ ] I'm
talking about to begin with I definitely
don't know what I'm talking about with
that I would I would go get some [ __ ]
therapy and just say I don't know what
it is
[ __ ] nothing gets me going and then
hopefully you you go to some asexual
specialist Jesus I'm the worst
sorry I let you down I'll give you a
podcast magnet next time I see you
alright 27 year old virgin Jesus Christ
hey Billy I'd love to hear your humorous
take on my pathetic situation first of
all dude let's work on your self-esteem
all right you're already [ __ ] all
over yourself alright watch this guy
watch him [ __ ] all over himself I'm a 27
year old virgin ojg that's what he wrote
now your first question is gonna be how
the [ __ ] did that happen well to protect
myself I'd actually prefer to keep my
background as quiet as possible hey I'm
not trying to get you to rat yourself
out
here's what I can say I come from a rich
town inhabited by obnoxious [ __ ] I was
always the weird kid and very socially
awkward people hated me no matter how
nice I was Jesus Christ dude are you
like a superhero that's like the exact
same background of like every [ __ ]
superhero movie isn't it because nerds
write those movies because they don't
how to fight and all of a sudden they're
like what do I knew how to play what if
I could fly and then they draw it and
then nerds line up around the block to
go see it
did you see the new spider-man yes it's
exactly like the other ones I was always
the weird kid and very socially awkward
people hated me no matter how nice I was
and eventually I came to hate myself and
still do I called it dude I [ __ ]
called it he's [ __ ] all over himself
eventually it was discovered that I most
likely have a mild case of Asperger's
syndrome which is a mild form of autism
which is way out of my league are you
guys trying to make me look dumb I
thought I did that I achieved that by
how awful I read out loud here we go
that causes social ineptitude and quirky
personality traits well I would go find
a hooker with Asperger's that's the
first thing I would do and get the
[ __ ] VIII off my back definitely wear
a condom see that's where my advice is
gonna be coming from you guys have some
weird conversation in some ironic
vehicle
um at least discovering this made me
more of self-aware and I've been able to
clean up my act over the last few years
but I still have a lot of social anxiety
and shyness and very few friends on the
flip side I'm actually pretty decent
looking have a decent job in a
laboratory these are [ __ ] he's got to
get bit by something radioactive and
he's gonna become a superhero and I'm a
certified commercial pilot and do
volunteer work dude like you know
something if if I was in the FBI like so
many [ __ ] red flags just went up
there okay that's the setup now now for
the question first what the [ __ ] would
you do if you were in my situation I
told you I'd get a hooker with
Asperger's syndrome and you guys could
just bond over that uh I don't know let
me let me read all these questions I'm
obviously kidding about trying to find a
hooker with Asperger's syndrome all
right
you couldn't find one that would be like
a needle in the haystack what you'd have
to do is go to an escort service and
request that personally I would think
I'm looking for 36-24-36 with Asperger
her color does not matter yes I can hold
next if eventually everything I ever do
make it anywhere with the chick should I
tell her upfront about my status I had
this conversation a few weeks ago with a
friend who has a lot of romantic
experience and she said it would be
extremely obvious that I'm new to the
game and that withholding that
information could itself be detrimental
but I also know that if I do tell a
chick I'm twenty-seven year old virgin
she will demand an explanation before
going any further and will send up red
flags for the most what do you do bill
thanks for doing your awesome podcast
and go [ __ ] yourself I this is what I
would do I would just start hitting on
every chick that [ __ ] interests me
and I would be just totally honest tell
him tell her what your your your
situation is and you know if she doesn't
accept it then [ __ ] her let her walk and
then you don't have to deal with any of
the
or you just you just fast-forward
through a three-year [ __ ] horrific
relationship I would just be upfront
people I wouldn't open it with hey you
have beautiful eyes and I have Asperger
I wouldn't do that you know I would work
on my self-esteem I wouldn't talk [ __ ]
you just you [ __ ] on yourself right out
of the gate I mean obviously I knew
you're gonna do that when you said you
were 27 year old virgin and and you're
probably gonna go that route but uh
think good thoughts about yourself man I
know that's kind of like simple but I
you know you gotta like you gotta amp
yourself up a little bit go out there
and you know you don't have to go find
the chickie your dreams but just go out
you don't got to tell some girl you got
[ __ ] Asperger's syndrome you don't
why don't you just do that with somebody
that you're really interested in but you
just want to go out and get laid just go
out there start hitting on chicks turn
it into a game so you don't to deal with
the pain of the rejection just be like
all right I don't have the balls to take
the next step whatever that step is
peeling yourself off the [ __ ] wall
striking up a conversation just saying
hello to a pretty girl she walks down
the street just try to get over that
[ __ ] hurdle and give you a permit
yourself permission to suck and you just
you gradually build it up it's like
learning how to play guitar you're not
gonna pick it up and immediately be able
to play all your songs you learn a
couple of [ __ ] chords you know then
your fingers hurt all right you get
frustrated but you keep coming back and
eventually you can [ __ ] play [ __ ] is
no different that's what I would do put
the ass burger on the back burner who
knows - maybe you're not as [ __ ] up as
you think you are socially you know what
I mean maybe you got a sense of humor
under that I think you do you [ __ ] on
yourself in a funny way
you know spin it around that way do you
have any interests go go - oh go to a
[ __ ] I don't know whatever you know
you fly kites go to some flying a kite
convention there's got to be some woman
there who also likes kites I know that
was an overly simplified thing by that's
what I would do all right and then when
you go to like hook up with somebody
nice you know and you yet tell them if
you start you don't know what you're
doing to watch a couple of [ __ ]
pornos you know you'll get the idea
actually no don't do that don't do that
because then you'll [ __ ] start
slapping them around you don't do that I
don't what to tell you dude I've right
buy some books I say go buy some buy
some books in that that uh that that
part of the bookstore that you know if
bookstores exist anymore
go on go online there's got to be plenty
of information I bet if you literally
looked up finger-banging technique if
you looked how to kiss I bet this just
gonna be reams of [ __ ] information
I've never done that because I never had
to just kiddin of course I had to you
think that I didn't wish that [ __ ]
information was around way back in the
day when he had no idea just practice it
kissing your [ __ ] pillow and tried to
overhear conversations in the [ __ ]
high school cafeteria and try to figure
out what people were talking about
that's all I had could do you let you
have the whole world at your fingertips
you know so when you're done in the
laboratory working with radioactive [ __ ]
before you big ya get bit by something
you don't want you go on get laid before
you learn how to fly alright alright
personal dilemma hey Bill hey Bill hey
Bill read my [ __ ] letter I got some
oh look who woke up what's up buddy how
are you you want to go outside when we
make my doghouse this is Cleo you want
go side Cleo she's dancing around Cleo
Clio do you try to go low Clio come here
Clio
you know I feel right now I feel like
him that Bugs Bunny cartoon when that
bullfrog is singing hello my baby hello
my honor you know no you guys are here
so she won't do it Clio
now she's licking herself I'm not gonna
[ __ ] be able to top that
alright personal dilemma hey Bill a few
days ago a good friend of mine lost her
dad and a motorcycle accident Jesus
Christ is there any ray of sunshine at
the end of these we started off well
let's let's just rewind here let's see
where the [ __ ] we how we got to this
point alright started off validation my
son's a nut job that was kind of
whatever surprise we're getting a
divorce
I blew somebody at work holy [ __ ] then
we go asexual
[ __ ] whip that around and then we can
hit the 27 year old virgin now now we're
talking about death okay
and none of this am I qualified to talk
about um bill a few days ago a good
friend of mine lost her dad in a
motorcycle accident it's obviously an
incredible emotional time for her and
her mother much younger brother my
family her dead this is such an awful
joke did they stare that sticks his
stick figure like picture off the back
of the SUV sorry I had to lighten it up
I had to lighten it up I'm sorry
alright her dad loves his motorcycles
and would take it across the continent
with his buddy and his wife and he had
his kids on dirt bikes since they were
young everyone is giving all the support
they can and will continue to do so in
time during this tough time uh last week
my buddy and I both bought our first
motorcycles and I've been really excited
to get it out on the road we both put
over 15 grand until not only our bikes
but riding gear in two courses obviously
this is pretty bad timing and we can't
cancel a reschedule the first course or
else we both give a grant to these dicks
for nothing the course is next weekend
and we're not sure whether or not we
should go under the circumstance
if the funeral falls within that weekend
it's obviously more important but if not
should we take the course I told her
about the bike and dude this is [ __ ]
hilarious
this is [ __ ] hilarious this guy is
trying to act like he really cares about
this guy and he's trying to way whether
I go take my Fonzarelli course or go to
the [ __ ] funeral
I thought the stick figure was a bad
joke now I don't feel bad about it all
right I told her about the bike and
courses before the accident so hiding it
really isn't an option I don't think she
would want us anywhere near a bike after
this okay I see what you're doing all
right I strike that strike what I just
said I've been close with this girl for
a while and I don't want to do anything
that might make this situation work
worse my buddy and I both know this
sounds incredibly [ __ ] selfish and if
we had the option of even rescheduling
we would have done it but a grant to a
student is a lot of money and we don't
want to give it to these pricks I love
how these guys are pricks how they
pricks these turn that pricks they have
a business they said what it was up
front they didn't jack it up you paid it
for him you're trying to make them out
to be the bad guys here but we also want
to offend and make her and maybe make
offend her and maybe make things worse
if that's even possible at this point
what should we do thanks dude you want
to go to this [ __ ] course in the
worst way you give a [ __ ] you care but
you don't want to lose your [ __ ]
money yeah I mean a thousand bucks is a
thousand bucks I don't know what to tell
you you've got to answer that one on
your own dude but you want to go you
definitely want to go if there was a way
for you to go and not go to the funeral
without getting in trouble you would
[ __ ] do it in a second and it has
nothing to do with those [ __ ] pricks
with their business all right you know
who's kidding hope dude with all the
[ __ ] dancing and skipping around
there you want to [ __ ] go learn how
to ride a motorcycle
your $15,000 motorcycle all right with
your punky Tuscadero outfit you want to
go put that on
is there a way
for you to [ __ ] go to the course and
then come back dude this is what you do
you go take the course that day alright
and hopefully the funeral is at night
and right as the service starts you come
flying back on your bike and then a
tribute to that guy who died on a
motorcycle you come through right
through the [ __ ] church doors on the
motorcycle and when everybody [ __ ]
gasped you just yell out alright
continue on with the service that's what
you do
alright that's my advice if you're gonna
[ __ ] do it because I know you want to
do it what you're wrestling with right
now sir is the selfish [ __ ] within you
and I'm not judging you I am I'm
relating good luck alright snot chicks
oh wait I haven't done any advertising
this week all right here we go here we
go here we go oh I forgot to mention
this today's show is brought to you by I
feel like I'm on Sesame Street the
number three in a letter L today's show
is brought to you by audible please
visit audible podcast.com slash bill for
your free audiobook download do you like
books but don't want to read them they
got a free audiobook download for you at
audible podcast.com slash bill look at
that I give you bad advice yet I bring
it around with free stuff okay um what
are we doing here what am I doing here
audible podcast.com slash bill go there
get a free audiobook download check out
their website listen to the podcasts and
all that type of stuff have a good time
with that there we go can you tell can
you tell them I'm trying to look for
other stuff here as I'm doing this hang
on hang on hang on hang on hang on eric
clapton hang on that's sent mail I
wanted to go into the Inbox Christ what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
oh Jesus guess who's back stamps calm
everybody stamps calm okay let's get
through this one cuz I know you guys got
to have this one memorized at this point
do you guys like going to the pod to the
podcast to the post office huh maybe you
do maybe a dump but would it be nice if
that was one more thing off the list of
things to do that day you could just
cross off would it be great if you just
could handle it within your own
apartment
home or sleeping bag would it be great
if you could print official u.s. stamps
off of your computer what if they gave
you a little scale you got to buy the
Hat but what if they gave you a little
scale you could you could just weigh
boxes put the official US postage take
it right out to the post-office box you
could do it 2:00 in the morning while
eating cereal watching reruns of The
Jeffersons well you can do that at
stamps com anything to do with the post
office you can do right now from your
desk with stamps calm unlike the post
office stamps calm never closes so you
get postage whenever you need it
24/7 I've been using these things
sending all my DVDs through stamps calm
I you I love using my scale and all that
type of stuff you get a no risk trial
plus a one hundred and ten dollar bonus
offer it includes a digital scale and up
to fifty five dollars in free postage
don't wait go to stamps calm before you
do anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Burpee URR that stamps calm
enter BRR be URR
there we go and what else do we got uh
the last two you want to get him out of
the way amazon.com you know the deal go
to Bill burr comm slash podcast okay or
bill burr calm you click on the podcast
page and you look on the right side
you'll see the amazon banner you click
on that and if you want to buy something
if you buy something not saying you have
to they kick a little bit of money to me
and I take 10% of that and I kick it to
the Wounded Warriors Project actually to
be honest with you what I'm starting to
do is just 10% of everything I make on
this all this advertising I'm just
sending to the Wounded Warriors Project
so if you do any of this stuff you're
gonna be helping out vets and and this
podcast it's a win win you can feel good
about yourself game if not saying you
don't already are
gamefly.com are you a gamer or do you
just look like one gamefly.com offers
over 8,000 video games they sent discs
in the mail to you and you can send them
you can send them back when you're done
there's no late fees no hassles mianne
with access to all new releases works
for your PlayStation Nintendo Wii Xbox
and now your PC for my listeners 8000
video games at your fingertips second
you're done you can send them back like
a bunch of [ __ ] you never love to
begin with I mean keep the one keep the
special ones you keep that one you keep
the soulmate games for my listeners you
can get a free 15 day to 2 disc trial
2295 value if you go to my website
podcast page and click on the game fly
banner or go to WWE and fly calm / /
check it out there you go look at that
post office is in your house 8000 video
games in your house audible podcast.com
you got that going on send some flowers
to your check you're gonna have a great
week you can have a great week oh look
I'm gonna go buy a widget on amazon.com
you just helped out the troops who's a
hero you are not me not me I'm just a
messenger I'm just I'm an open channel I
just let it flow right through me
alright smart bill you're an American
Hero
are you talking to me for what if I did
III must know somebody at the American
Hero Awards nepotism my dad started it
so he just gave me one um smart chicks
mad chicks my girlfriend dumped me
because she could sniff out my BS before
I even realized it smelled
she was definitely smarter than me
because after I was through pouting
about being dumped I realized she was
right that's very mature you know you're
not that dumb there's a lot of smart
guys you know they can't do they think
Albert Einstein would do that some chick
who's smarter than him he could [ __ ]
handle that with his phil spector
haircut before Phil Spector Tom Selleck
mustache alright so here's my question
how do I make smart chicks dumber thanks
for your help
don't go [ __ ] yourself [ __ ] others okay
uh this guy's a wiseass
I like him how do you make smart chicks
dumber um alright this is what you do I
don't care who they are they got to have
some sort of physical thing that you can
tell it they're that they're sensitive
about okay maybe they have little arms
like that little hot Italian chick on
the Food Network you know every time she
goes to reach something like her arms
are always totally straight or else she
can't get it yet she somehow like 5 foot
2 that's what you do he just looked for
something ok and then you focus on that
anytime she starts being smarter you
bring up our little arms you know
you bet you gradually destroy her spirit
that's how you do it now
do you want to do that I hope you don't
because if you do then seriously go [ __ ]
yourself sorry anyways let's go dilemmas
bill would you rather gain a three pack
a day smoking habit or have to wear a
dress for the rest of your life oh I
take a dress all day long I take all
[ __ ] day long I would get some
[ __ ] fruity smelling shampoo to wash
what's left of my hair and I'd wear I'd
wear it down the street you know what I
would do it I would start hanging out in
coffee houses and act like I played
guitar and I'd probably get more ass
than I ever did as opposed to [ __ ] 3
pack a day smoking habit there's no
final and do that then what died earlier
I'll be on my deathbed going out as your
war dress still be alive the Bruins
still at first place would you rather
have a third nipple in the center of
your chest or a third testicle Oh
without question I take the third ball
all day long who the [ __ ] is gonna see
it you know and then if I ever get
kicked in the balls
I got one that can get out of the way so
maybe it can like somehow offset the
pain of one it only feels like like when
Lance gets kicked in the balls does that
make any sense I mean
I don't know when when is a girl really
gonna what does a girl really even look
at your balls you know it's funny I
could have three balls and my girl
wouldn't know you know I never noticed
that course you didn't it's all [ __ ]
inflated and not inflated and shipped in
and it's it's like I don't know what it
is it's like a ball sack I don't even
know what the [ __ ] is in there yeah it's
no another one in there I don't give a
[ __ ]
supposed to having that third one
sitting there looking like a late-model
Ford 1948 Ford it was at the no what was
that guy that Tim Robbins that car Tim
Robbins made in that movie Tucker
looking like the front end of one of
those Tucker's yeah I'm not doing that
having a third headlight no [ __ ] way
no way there's not enough makeup to
cover that up but you know whatever
throw something else in my ball bag hey
you know what I say about my ball bag
the more the merrier how do you like
that all right and with that that's the
podcast for this week everybody up nice
and early it's able to be downloaded
perfectly what could you think about
bitching about next who knows
please visit me on Twitter I'm almost up
to 100,000 followers you know and I
think once I got to 100,000 that's gonna
be critical mass and that's when I can
really start hitting you guys with my
conspiracy theories and possibly start
getting a little momentum you know
that's it okay this week everybody I'm
gonna be at the DC Improv it's already
sold out but I'm gonna bring it up just
so I can tell you that it's sold out you
know like when they have a poster up on
the wall and they just stamp sold out on
it's like well then why you still
advertising it to rub it in then I'm not
going I'm at the DC Improv down I'm out
there to celebrate celebrate their
[ __ ] 30th anniversary it's one of my
favorite clubs of all time you know
there's some special ones out there ones
that I dreamed of playing and that is
one of them how do you like that
endorsement people at the DC improv I
love them so much and would be there in
a Tuesday ah Jesus you know what I just
tried to overly cross my leg over the
top of the armrest here and I just
crushed one of my balls for a second
you know why do you think that just
happened do you think my house is
haunted do you think that was maybe
somebody who used to live here named
Ulysses who was killed by a bunch of
[ __ ] mean neighborhood kids because
they found out he had three balls and
now I finally brought it up and I
Unleashed him you know what I think I'm
gonna call ghost hunter and it's gonna
grace the the ghost of three ball Larry
and you know what's funny about that
[ __ ] ridiculous goddamn show is they
would actually show up to film it you
know you know I want to I want to film
them film in my place and catch them
when they throw that rock down the hall
vehicle oh what the [ __ ] was that did
you feel soft oh I definitely felt
something you know that show is it's
like a bunch of Paul versys chasing
ghosts all right you want you only have
the biggest the biggest [ __ ] scam
ever and this is such a big fight
between me and Mia all the time is the
use of the [ __ ] dishwasher
I think the dishwasher is one of the
biggest scams other than the Federal
Reserve it goes Federal Reserve ice
cubes anger and then the dishwasher and
you can throw skip bayless in there
somewhere
his his screaming and yelling somewhere
you can throw it in there somewhere I
don't give a [ __ ] you know it's all it's
all up to personal opinion the
dishwasher it doesn't [ __ ] wash
dishes and I know this is a Seinfeld bit
why they should call it the would would
you yeah it doesn't it doesn't the
dishwasher does not scrub the dishes it
basically like you ever take a piss and
there's a skid mark in the toilet and
you just start peeing on it that's what
a dishwasher does you know so basically
if the food has been there long enough
it's not coming off all right and my leg
will [ __ ] put dishes in there and
they'll stay in there for [ __ ] days
and then she runs it and it gets it gets
most of it done
you know and then I go out to make
myself an egg and there's [ __ ] dinner
from [ __ ] three nights ago a couple
of like skid marks in toilet lasagna
skid marks on the [ __ ] plates it
drives me nuts
I had a hissy fit everybody
okay I I literally I had a hissy fit
I'll even call it that if you saw it you
would have laughed your asses off
because I was here by myself cursing and
screaming when I couldn't figure out why
we didn't have any [ __ ] Forks where
are the forks and then I finally was
like you know what I bet they're in the
goddamn dishwasher and I went over and
opened dishwasher and there was like
[ __ ] ten plates in there all with
this [ __ ] that you couldn't get off yet
I have to hire one of those [ __ ] guys
who paints cars at this point to come
over here with that sandblasted to get
this [ __ ] off and you know I'm talking
too much about this [ __ ] but the dish
dishwasher is completely it's a scam it
doesn't [ __ ] work and for some reason
it adds value to your house when people
show up does it have a dishwasher oh
honey they you know oh Jesus you built
you know it's you're an hour and 15
minutes in you gave them their [ __ ]
money's worth do you really need to end
it with your goofy little riff about
dishwashers do you think other people
never use them and realise that they
don't quite [ __ ] work you're stupid
[ __ ] alright that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves we'll talk to you next week
you